[Music]
then you listen there was no snoozing
during my interview with gal gadot
unless she could sleep standing up
because that's what she was doing you
know she's fighting her way through
major major back pain but nothing that
can stop Wonder Woman
huh look you got a stand though are you
okay uh yeah I'm okay just threw my back
out it happens because of her bad back
Gau stood during my interview she also
has her hands full as a new mom what's
really bothered me is sitting so I can
stand and lay down so when I'm standing
I'm with a baby and I'm you know you
find you just work around it her second
child daughter Maya was born in March
now I can't see a baby bump under that
skin tight Wonderwoman suit but for some
of the scenes it was there you were
pregnant when you were filming parts of
this still yeah impede anything we shot
the movie and then I went straight into
justice Leah got pregnant when I was
shooting justice again at the end of
justice again to do some additional
photography for this one so I was five
months pregnant and I just had a funny
costume
they cut a big triangle and painted
green and I came to work me and Maya we
came to work together in the film gal
grows up as Diane on a secret island of
female warriors when we were shooting
this battle scene back in Italy I felt
the sisterhood there was so much fun all
of us women working together it was
surreal too because all the men came to
be with with the wives or girlfriends
and they had they were walking around
with strollers it was like a no chair
yeah exactly it was so much fun for
everyone
[Music]
you